i think
i'm finally ready
to talk everyone i'm abby sharp welcome
to abby's kitchen
[Music]
[Music]
we will be reviewing ilana molstein and
beachbody's 2b weight loss program but
first let me tell you about my sponsor
cook unity so as a food blogger and
cookbook author i have spent a lot of
time in the kitchen but i'm also really
busy mom of two and a business owner so
there's a lot of days when i just can't
sometimes i don't have the inspiration
sometimes i don't have the time
sometimes i don't have the ingredients
and sometimes i just don't have the
drive so whenever we're down south in
the states we always stock up on some of
the creative signature meals from cook
unity cook unity has over 50 talented
chefs from some of the best restaurants
in the country working out of regional
micro kitchens instead of massive
production facilities so you feel like
you're getting a restaurant meal at home
basically you let them know what you
like and what you don't like and you
pick a flexible meal plan so you can get
as few as four or as many as 16 meals
per week then you can select from
hundreds of meals that align with your
preferences and dietary restrictions and
they use all really high quality chef
driven ingredients the meals are
delivered fresh not frozen in
compostable recycling or reusable
packaging along with expiration dates
heating instructions and nutrition stats
and then a few days before your delivery
you get a text to make all your
selections for the next week it feels
like one huge thing off my plate that i
just can't screw up everything i've
tried is amazing and the menu rotates
constantly with a wide range of
different cultural flavors and
preparations so it really helps to fill
the gaps with inspiring fun meals for
those nights when things get super
hectic so if you want to try cook unity
for yourself go to
cookunity.com or click the link in the
description and use my code abby 50 to
get 50 off of your first order of meals
and of course don't forget to pause this
screen or look at my description for my
general disclaimer including a trigger
warning as we will be discussing
restrictive dieting and also a reminder
that this is not a critique of elana
personally but i will be sharing my
perspective on her program and some of
her posts and if you're new here don't
forget to subscribe to this channel ring
that bell and follow me over on
instagram and tick tock at abby's
kitchen all right folks today we are
going where i don't think i have ever
gone before okay slash that i did talk
about pick up limes once but today
we are back and we're going to talk
about another fellow registered
dietitian and as always i'm going to
approach this with respect and the
acknowledgement that different coaching
approaches are going to work for
different people and this is absolutely
nothing against ilana herself but so so
so many of you have sent me alana's
content from social media and her
beachbody program to be so i am finally
ready to unpack it all so let's take a
look at some of the major themes that
i've seen on ilana's feed and tell you a
little bit about how i feel about those
posts first of all i think it's a rarity
nowadays to see a wellness influencer
unapologetically talk about weight loss
and not try to disguise it as some kind
of wellness tactic you know that i'm not
obviously a hardcore weight loss rd
myself but i can appreciate when someone
is just transparent about their mo yeah
that's me
even though intentional weight loss has
kind of fallen out of style a lot of
people
still want to lose weight so i do prefer
her direct and honest approach over the
sneaky this is not a diet approach that
we see so often today
noom
um where was i but anyways i really do
think for the most part alana has an
evidence-based all foods can fit
approach she's not promoting any
outrageous elimination diets cleanses
detoxes or magical pseudoscience hacks
she knows as we all do that at the end
of the day weight loss comes down to
calories consumed minus calories burned
though of course if you are a regular
abby's kitchen subbie you also know that
it's not actually that simple things
are not as easy
for some people that they are for our
people so we occasionally even see alana
acknowledge some of the crazy
fear-mongering statements out there when
it comes to food we see her discouraging
extreme diets that result in kind of a
last supper or cheat day mentality and
we even see her promoting actually
eating as a method to disrupt binge
eating behavior yes yes
yes
so
rather than telling people to
intermittent fast or drink green juice
or take a specific supplement to lose
weight i would characterize elana's
approach to what we often call
volume eating alana calls it her more
sure model while beachbody's 2b program
has trademarked this as water first
veggies most english bothers me but
anyways all of this is basically
centered around this concept of filling
up on low calorie volumis foods to trick
yourself into eating less so alana
recommends drinking your water first
then eating your vegetables then having
protein then your carbs and if you're
still hungry you can have more and this
theory is backed up by some science so
we do have research that drinking water
before a meal can reduce the caloric
consumption in the meal that follows
likely because the temporary stretching
of the vagus nerve tells the brain that
the stomach is getting full but we don't
know if this makes a difference in the
course of the day or if those calories
are made up for once your body kind of
figures out that you've tried to dupe it
into eating less don't forget that our
bodies really want us consuming enough
calories to thrive and maintain its
setpoint weight so i'm not convinced
that this wouldn't eventually catch up
with most people over time either in
tiny amounts unconsciously or in a
full-out binge as for the suggestion to
specifically fill up on vegetables
before protein and carbs this is a
classic diet suggestion with kind of
like a bit of a weight watchers vibe
since vegetables are high in water and
fiber and very low cow so the more you
can again stretch your stomach out the
less physical space you'll have for food
with like
actual calories but as elana mentions in
her instagram reel here did you know
that the order in which you eat your
meal actually makes a difference studies
have found that if your first bite is
high in carbohydrates your blood sugar
response after the meal will be higher
than if you started by eating veggies
and your protein first even if the whole
meal is exactly the same how cool there
is some newer research describing a
different mechanism for why this
approach might work you've maybe seen
some influencers suggest that there's
almost like a buffering effect on
insulin levels when you consume your
vegetables and protein before you eat
your carbs and there are some small
studies and research in the diabetes
population showing some benefits to this
method so i don't want to dismiss it at
all but you also don't need to separate
out your food unnaturally if you're
eating a mixed meal let's say like a
pasta with veggies and a meat bolognese
sauce then you're gonna get those
insulin stabilizing benefits a la my
hunger crushing combo even if your first
bite doesn't
contain like a honking piece of veg more
importantly in the context of weight
loss as we discussed in detail in my
insulin video here this mechanism may be
more of interest for folks with insulin
resistance and diabetes and less so for
straight up weight loss in the healthy
population so it may play a more nuanced
indirect role but not nearly as much as
just filling your plate with low calorie
water and veggies most as ilana and
beachbody suggest now if you take a
closer look at alana's feed you'll see
plenty of examples of these low carb low
calorie high volume meals and she also
even describes herself as a proud volume
eater so is this a healthy way to eat
well
as usual i have some thoughts for one i
think what makes sense about the core
principles of volume eating or the water
first veggies most or more sure or
whatever you want to call it is that it
encourages you to eat more fruits and
veg and that's great we love to see it
most people are not eating enough
vegetables and fruit which means they're
missing out on powerful health-promoting
antioxidants phytonutrients and fiber
and fiber is not just important for
satiety and therefore making weight loss
easier but it's also really important
for regularity and by supporting our gut
microbiome for literally everything else
immunity mental health heart health
blood sugar regulation all depend on a
healthy gut all good things in my books
yep
yes but
it's not a perfect model and here's why
one whether consciously or unconsciously
these approaches demonize fat or other
nutrient dense foods like fat isn't even
represented on that more sure wheel
which insinuates that it is not
important or it should be consumed as
little as possible and honestly i worry
that a lot of dieting women already
don't get enough healthy fats in their
day in reality we know that a diet rich
in unsaturated fats like nuts seeds
avocado and olive oil help to support
hormones and fertility heart health gut
health and satiety a lab my hunger
crushing combo especially the
plant-based unsaturated fats so
personally and professionally i'm all
for promoting healthy bodies over skinny
bodies and healthy bodies especially
female bodies need fat we also can't
forget that overeating water and
vegetables might yield a low calorie day
that could contribute to weight loss but
when taken to an extreme as it often is
can also cause one to look and feel very
distended bloated and uncomfortable so
even if you're losing fat or weight you
might actually feel and look much bigger
i know for myself when i have a really
healthy day and i have a more volumist
salad as a meal i look noticeably much
larger than days that i eat just like
straight up pasta and bread so that's
only to consider if you've got a
sensitive gut or you're not used to
loading up on water and fiber and then
there's the psychological side of things
i get that the selling point of this
approach is that you can still eat the
foods you love and if you have a big
appetite you can eat a lot of food but
it's worth sitting down to ask yourself
why do you have such a big appetite
maybe your body actually just needs more
calories not more water like stretching
at your stomach maybe you actually need
more food or maybe your overwhelming
desire to eat all day is telling you
something about your relationship with
food volume eating isn't inherently
problematic but it absolutely can be a
crutch for folks struggling with
disordered eating trigger warning for
what i'm about to say but filling up on
massive salads and low-carb doodle bowls
are all common tactics of pro-ana forums
so for some folks volume eating is often
used as a stand-in for a binge but
without the caloric damage and even
though you might feel full and have the
physical sensation of your stomach
expanding dragging yourself through a
huge huge bowl of kale with maybe like a
tiny bit of chicken on top might just
not be very satisfying or in alana's
case a huge blender worth of snickers
froyo made of frozen zucchini which i
can't imagine tastes exactly like a
snickers you know how we talk about
going on the satisfaction hunt well i
see that a lot with volume eaters and in
the end it often can just perpetuate
obsessive thoughts about food i.e the
actual snickers bar that you're trying
to avoid i know for me and for so many
others one of the most telling signs of
recovery from my ed was when i no longer
wanted to volume eat when i no longer
had the desire to chew salad for 30
minutes because i had space in my life
to fill with other things i am not
suggesting that alana is promoting eds
absolutely not but what i'm saying is
that volume eating can be a trigger or a
crutch for some folks who've struggled
with their relationship with food and
that brings me to my thoughts on her 2b
program with beachbody oh god here we go
again now according to their website the
program's goal is to help you lose
weight while still enjoying your
favorite foods which is an approach i
can absolutely get aligned with
okay unlike the 20 day portion fix
program that we talked about here where
you have to fit food into special
containers the 2b program suggests you
start your meal with 16 ounces of water
and then stick to their suggested plate
proportions for vegetables fiber-rich
carbs and protein so again right off the
bat our beloved fat has been forgotten
about and when oil is included in
recipes for cooking for example it often
comes with some kind of cautionary tale
on how you should limit it now i want to
note that i actually generally like a
plate method like this for nutrition
education i do think that aiming to fill
half of your plate with veggies and
fruit can be a relatively gentle
nutrition suggestion i also am not
completely opposed their emphasis on
tracking what you eat i don't think that
we need to track every calorie and macro
but there is research to support using a
food diary to support weight loss and if
writing down general estimates of what
you eat helps you learn about your body
and what foods make you feel best then i
do think that it could be a useful tool
for some folks so in the grand scheme of
weight loss diets this all seems
relatively benign that is until you
check out the suggested meal plan here's
a sample day so breakfast portions are
50
high fiber carbs and 50 protein so
obviously we're starting the day with a
smoothie using shakeology protein powder
shakeology greens powder and shakeology
digestive health powder so i hope you
like supporting mlms now we've got just
a half a banana worth of carbs in there
which is really nothing to write home
about in my books and we're allowed a
tablespoon of almond butter for fat it
certainly is a light breakfast and
wouldn't be enough for me but what i
hate most here is the recipe tip at the
bottom that if you can't trust yourself
with a jar of almond butter to use
fat-free peanut powder instead so
yeah we're off to a problematic start
now lunch proportions are 50 veggies 25
carbs and 25 protein which i think is
the most ideal and balanced plate of the
day i think this salad sounds really
delicious but again it's feeling
super low carb a small apple and a
little olive oil is not going to add
much so i do worry that most people
would not feel emotionally satisfied
despite its volume of size now the tip
on this meal reads that if you want to
turn this into a dinner to just
eliminate the apple aka turn it into the
most flavorless sad meal of life now if
this was my meal i would love to see a
little whole food fat in there like some
avocado or nuts and a piece or two of
some high fiber pita bread on the side
and that brings me to dinner portions
which are not surprisingly 75 veggies
and 25 protein and obviously i am hungry
already so here we've got a very low
calorie low carb meal made of
cauliflower and a single egg cooked with
non-stick cooking spray and a teaspoon
of sesame oil for flavor i would be
going to bed a very hungry and
unsatisfied after that meal and i would
say most people would because the day
clocks in at under 1200
calories is that bad
it sounds bad
that is less than what my toddler eats
in a day hard stop the program suggests
that if you are really hungry you can
have a snack but i do worry that because
it's not written in to the official menu
that most people are going to try to
muscle through and do without so i think
the concept has a lot of potential and
makes a lot of sense i mean i'm all for
encouraging folks to eat their veg but
not if your meals leave you hangry and
sad you're not a child you are a grown
ass adult and if forcing yourself to eat
foods that you do not like makes you
unhappy or hungry you're gonna rebel
you're gonna snap and you're likely
going to eventually binge and that's not
the only questionable post i've seen
lately that has raised some eyebrows
especially since some of them seem to
contradict her earlier more gentle
posts so this one for example about
throwing junk food away because wasting
actual food is apparently better than
the possibility of carrying body fat
yeah it felt elitist and inadvertently
fat phobic in my opinion now maybe she's
on her own body journey right now and
maybe this militant tough love approach
works for her
are you ready to work
are you ready to work but research
suggests it's not appropriate for most
people and it's absolutely not without
risks so in conclusion well i respect a
wide range of clinical approaches and
i'm confident that elana's program
specifically has helped a number of
people lose weight it's not going to be
for everyone especially for a lot of you
who i know need a much more gentle
approach i think the core of the 2b
program makes absolute sense and has the
potential to help support a more
balanced lifestyle for weight management
but it can also be very risky without
proper flexibility customization and a
strong relationship with food so on that
note that is all that i have for you
guys today if you like this video please
feel free to give it the thumbs up leave
me a comment below with your thoughts on
the program or other weight loss
programs that you want to see me review
subscribe to the channel and i will see
you next time on abby's kitchen bye
[Music]